the staging of cervical cancer refers to
the extent of the disease dr. stage the
disease according to the size of the
tumor and whether it has spread to
nearby tissues or other organs of the
body stage 0 is not considered invasive
because the cancer cells are found only
in the top layer of cells of the cervix
stage 1a is considered invasive cancer
because the microscopic tumor grows
through the top layer of cells into the
underlying cervical tissue and is three
to five millimeters deep by 7
millimeters wide stage 1b cervical
cancer has two scenarios one where the
tumor still can only be seen with a
microscope but is larger than five
millimeters deep and 7 millimeters wide
in the second scenario for stage 1b the
cancer can be seen without a microscope
and is larger than four centimeters in
diameter in stage 2a the tumor spreads
beyond the cervix to the upper
two-thirds of the vagina but not to the
tissues around the uterus in stage 2b
the cancer spreads to the tissues around
the uterus in stage 3a the tumor spreads
to the lower third of the vagina in
stage 3b the cancer spreads to the
pelvic wall the lining of the body wall
cavity between the hips or it may spread
to the uterus tubes that carry urine
away from the kidneys to the bladder if
the flow of urine is blocked the kidneys
can become enlarged or stopped working
in stage 4 a
the tumor invades nearby pelvic organs
such as the bladder or rectum and may
spread to the pelvic lymph nodes
in stage 4 be the cancer spreads past
the pelvic lymph nodes to other places
in the body such as the liver intestines
or lungs